hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to talk about
expectation values in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
expectation values are a concept
borrowed from basic probability theory
and they allow us to characterize
probability distributions
the reason why they're useful in quantum
mechanics is because we know that the
information captured by a quantum state
can be represented by a probability
distribution
however we have to be careful when using
expectation values in quantum mechanics
because they're very often confused with
the outcome of measurements
it is important to realize that
expectation values and the outcomes of
measurements are two completely
different things in quantum mechanics
in this video we'll explain in detail
what expectation values are
and will make the distinction with
measurement outcomes crystal clear at
the end of the video we'll also see one
of the many applications of expectation
values
the root mean square deviation a
quantity that features in the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
so let's go
in this video we explore in some detail
the probabilistic nature of measurements
in quantum mechanics
and to start let's have a quick reminder
about measurements
we consider a physical quantity a and
the associated observable a that is a
hermitian operator
we also build the eigenvalue equation
for operator a where lambda n are the
eigenvalues
and u n the eigenstates postulate four
of quantum mechanics tells us that when
we measure
quantity a in a system in state psi the
outcome of the measurement
is eigenvalue lambda n with probability
p
given by the absolute value squared of
the bracket between the associated
eigenstate u n
and the state psi of the system remember
from the video representation that we
can expand our state psi
in the u basis in terms of c
coefficients
where these expansion coefficients are
simply given by the bracket between u
and psi and given this we can now also
rewrite the probability of measuring
eigenvalue lambda n
as the absolute value squared of cn as
shown up here
okay so feel free to pause here for a
second because we've gone quite quickly
over this
in reality we've covered this in much
more detail in the videos of
measurements
so if you want a more in-depth
description then feel free to check
those out before you proceed
so quantum mechanics doesn't tell us the
precise outcome of a measurement
what it tells us is the probability
associated with any given outcome
another way of understanding this
probabilistic interpretation is to
imagine that we have many exact copies
of the system in state psi
say n copies when we measure a for each
of these systems we can get
any of the possible eigenvalues as an
outcome say for the first one we get
lambda 2
for the second lambda 7 for the third
lambda 1
and so on let's say that we get
eigenvalue lambda n
a total of p n times
then what postulate 4 says is that when
the number of copies n of the system
tends to infinity
the fraction of measurements that give
lambda n which is pn over n
tends to the probability p lambda n
the ideas we have discussed in these two
initial slides should be familiar from
the videos on measurements
and if you haven't seen them then i
would encourage you to check them out
before proceeding
what we'll do in this video is to
consider two concepts from probability
and statistics
expectation values and root mean square
deviations and see how we can use them
to characterize quantum systems
to understand expectation values and
root mean square deviations it is very
useful to use a pictorial representation
let's draw a pair of axes on the
horizontal axis
we have the eigenvalues of the operator
a
and i am placing them at arbitrary
locations
let's also write down the state psi of
our system
and we consider its expansion in the
basis of eigenstates of the operator a
as usual these expansion coefficients
are given by the bracket between u
and psi we're now going to place the
probability p
of getting a particular eigenvalue as
the vertical axis
postulate 4 up here then tells us that
this probability p is equal to the
absolute value squared of the c
coefficients
so if we start with eigenvalue lambda 1
we get this
of height c1 squared and we can do the
same for the rest of eigenvalues
in this schematic i am using arbitrary
values for these c coefficients but in a
real situation we would get them from
this expression here
so what this diagram is showing is what
we call a probability distribution
the higher the lines the more likely we
will measure that particular outcome
so we know that in quantum mechanics we
cannot know the precise outcome of a
measurement before we perform it
what postulate thought tells us
precisely is the height
of these lines so it tells us precisely
what this probability distribution is
there is the reason why in this video
we'll explore how we can characterize
such probability distributions
in the rest of the video i will use a
discrete spectrum of eigenvalues for our
discussion to simplify notation
but all the ideas we'll discuss
trivially generalized to continuous
eigenvalue spectra
the only difference is that the
probability distribution becomes
continuous
say something like this
the next idea i want to explore is what
happens in the special case when the
state of our system is one of the
eigenstates of the operator associated
with the property that we want to
measure
in this case writing the state psi in
the u basis only has one term
say um this means that the expansion
coefficient
cm is equal to one while all other
expansion coefficients are zero
in turn this means that the probability
of measuring the associated eigenvalue
lambda
m is one so in this case there is
actually a hundred percent certainty
about the outcome of the measurement
put another way if the system is in an
eigenstate of the property we're
measuring
then the outcome of the measurement is
the associated eigenvalue with
probability 1.
if we now look again at the pictorial
representation we've been discussing
then the probability distribution has a
single peak of height 1 at the
corresponding eigenvalue
and all other values are 0.
so from our discussion so far all that
quantum mechanics teaches us about the
quantum state
is the probability distribution
associated with a particular
observable however probability
distributions can sometimes be rather
complex
which makes them cumbersome to work with
and many times can obscure understanding
so what we'll do in the rest of the
video is to define a number of
quantities that will allow us to
simplify the information
and code it in a probability
distribution this will come at the price
of losing some information
but the resulting quantities are very
useful in many problems
the first quantity that we define to
characterize probability distributions
is the expectation value
we've seen earlier that if we have a
very large number of copies of the
system
then quantum mechanics tells us the
exact fraction of measurements that will
give a particular outcome
in this context the expectation value
tells us the average value
of all these measurement outcomes
to make these statements concrete let's
consider a system in state psi
the expectation value of an observable a
in the system in a state psi
is written as the associated operator a
written between angle brackets
and with sub index indicating the state
psi of the system
very often we will work with the fixed
state psi and if there is no ambiguity
we typically simplify this expression
and omit the subindex
if we get eigenvalue lambda n with
probability p lambda
n then the average over all measurements
is simply the standard formula for an
average
so the expectation value of a is equal
to the sum over all n
of lambda n p lambda n
using the value of the probability that
postulate 4 gives us up here
we can rewrite this as sum over n of
lambda n
absolute value squared of u n psi
what i want to show next is that in
quantum mechanics we can calculate the
expectation value using an alternative
expression
the bracket between psi and then the
operator a acting on
psi to see why we start by inserting two
identities on either side of a
we then insert the resolutions of these
identities in the u bases as usual
then we move the sums to the beginning
and we end up with a double sum over
three terms
psi u n u n a um
um psi we can now use the fact that the
u basis is made of the eigenstate of the
a
operator to set this equal to lambda m
um
and we can then rewrite this entire
expression as sum over n
m of lambda m and then these three terms
the middle term is delta n m because the
basis is orthonormal
so we can perform the sum over m and end
up with sum over n
of lambda and absolute value squared of
the bracket u n
psi that is precisely the definition of
expectation value up here
so we can indeed write the expectation
value of a in the state psi
as psi a psi
okay so some of you may have seen
expectation values before and if you
have then this is probably the
expression that you have been working
with
what we see here is why it takes this
form
a quick comment before we move on we
typically work with normalized states
psi but if you were working with a state
site that is not normalized
then the expectation value can be very
easily generalized to this expression
in which we explicitly normalize by
dividing by the norm of
psi
many of you are probably familiar with
expectation values from a standard
probability
so most of what we have been discussing
will be familiar however when we start
learning about quantum mechanics
many of us confuse measurement outcomes
and expectation values
so it is very important to make sure
that these concepts are very clear
a question i often ask my students to
prop their understanding is the
following
imagine that we have a system in state
psi in that case
what value will we get when we measure a
many students respond this we calculate
the expectation value of a in state
psi now if you have been following you
will straight away know that it is the
wrong answer
you will also know what the right answer
is the value we'll get
is one of the eigenvalues of the
operator a but we cannot know which one
we'll get
all we can know is what is the
probability associated with each
possible outcome
to make this point extremely clear let's
imagine a very simple situation
consider a system with a two-dimensional
state space
and we write the eigenvalue equation of
operator a explicitly for the two
eigenstates
the first eigenstate is u plus with
eigenvalue plus one
and the second eigenstate is u minus
with eigenvalue minus 1.
now imagine that the state of our system
is psi and it is equal to 1 over square
root of 2
u plus plus u minus well the prefactor
is here to ensure normalization
so what are the possible outcomes of a
measurement of a if the system is in
this state psi
we have two possibilities we can get
eigenvalue plus one
with probability one-half and we can get
eigenvalue minus
with probability one-half and that's it
that's all we can say about the
measurement of a in this system
feel free to pause here for a second to
cross-check this but it should be clear
after a moment
so by comparison what's the expectation
value
we can write out one of the many
formulas we have for it
expanding the sum we get two terms the
eigenvalue plus one
multiplied by the dissociated
probability plus the eigenvalue -1
multiplied by its associative
probability
both probabilities are one-half so we
get this
which gives zero
so what do we have the result of the
measurement can only be plus one
or minus one but the expectation value
here is zero
so this shows very clearly that the
expectation value doesn't tell us
anything
about the possible outcomes of a
particular measurement in this
particular example
zero is not even a possible outcome of
the measurement
now that we've established this can we
understand why the expectation value in
this example is zero
our state is an equal superposition of
two eigenstates
if we made a very large number of
measurements about half would give plus
one
and about half would give minus one the
average of these two numbers
is indeed zero
pictorially we can again draw the axis
place the eigenvalues on the horizontal
axis
and the probability on the vertical axis
our probability distribution is then
this
and the expectation value is in the
middle of the distribution
it tells us the average of all outcomes
but in this particular example it
doesn't coincide with any possible
outcome
another important point about the
expectation value is what happens when
the state of the system is one of the
eigenstates of the operator
say um in this case the expectation
value is this
and using the eigenvalue equation here
we simply get lambda m um um
the basis is orthonormal so we get
lambda m
so in the special case of the state of
the system being an eigenstate of the
operator
then the expectation value is simply the
associated eigenvalue
in this special case the expectation
value does coincide with the outcome of
a measurement
but remember that this in general isn't
true
the expectation value is a useful
quantity but it only gives us a rough
idea about the probability distribution
to see why consider again our axis
and as an example imagine we have a red
probability distribution
and a blue one both distributions are
symmetric about the center
so their expectation values are the same
here
but if we only analyze these probability
distributions using expectation values
there would be no way of telling these
two distributions apart although they
obviously are very different
so this here is an example of the
limitations associated with using a
quantity like the expectation value
to characterize something like a
probability distribution which can be
rather complex
what i want to do next is to consider a
new quantity which will allow us to
distinguish to some extent
these two distributions and it will do
that by measuring their widths
which we can schematically represent
like this and like this
let's start by defining the mean square
deviation
to do that consider a new operator sigma
a
as equal to the operator a minus the
expectation value of the operator a
we define the mean square deviation as
the expectation value
of sigma a squared plugging in the
definition of sigma a we see that it is
given by this
expanding the square we get this
the expectation value of a scalar c is
just the scalar itself
and as the expectation value is just a
scalar then the expectation value of an
expectation value is equal to the
expectation
value so using this we can rewrite the
mean square deviation as the expectation
value of a
squared and then combining these two
terms we get minus the expectation value
of a
all squared
quantity that's typically used to
measure the width of the distribution is
the square root
of the mean square deviation and it is
done to ensure that the width has the
same units as the quantity that we're
working with
we therefore define the root mean square
deviation delta a
as the square root of the mean square
deviation
which you can also write down in terms
of this formula
so given this formula is there an easy
way to understand why this quantity
tells us information about the width of
the probability distribution
in this example the two distributions
have the same average in the middle
but different widths here and here
the sigma a is looking at how far we are
from the average
if we simply calculated the expectation
value of sigma a we would get 0 because
the average is by definition the middle
point of the distribution
so we have as many terms on one side as
on the other
contributing with opposite signs and
therefore canceling each other
this is why we instead have to calculate
the expectation value of the square
so that the terms on either side of the
average don't cancel
we then recover the correct units by
calculating the square root of this
expression
to finish let's look at the root mean
square deviation when the system is in
an eigenstate of the operator that we're
working with
let psi be um in this case the
expectation value of a is this
we can use the fact that um is an
eigenstate of a
and we simply get lambda m the
expectation value of a
squared is this
and using the eigenvalue equation twice
we end up with lambda m
squared we can now combine these two
results to calculate the root mean
square deviation
and it is given by this expression up
here and in our case it is the square
root of lambda m
squared minus lambda m all squared
this is zero and this tells us that the
probability distribution
has a width of zero so does this result
make sense
let's draw again our pair of axes with
the eigenvalues here
and the probability here we have already
discussed that when our state is an
eigenstate of the operator
then the probability distribution is
zero everywhere apart from the position
of the eigenvalue where it is one
as the root mean square deviation
measures the width of the distribution
then indeed it should be zero in this
case because the distribution is all
concentrated at a single point
the expectation value and the root mean
square deviation allow us to
characterize the probability
distribution that is associated with the
possible outcomes of a measurement in
quantum mechanics
the expectation value gives us the
average of the probability distribution
the root mean square deviation
characterizes its width we could
of course come up with many other
measures of probability distributions
but these two
are the most useful ones if you want to
see an example of why
check out the videos on the heisenberg
uncertainty principle and as always
if you liked the video please subscribe